what's going on guys this is Rob and I
get all kinds of questions from you guys
and one of the questions came from
Marvel nur who asked is it worth getting
Marvel unlimited and what are the pros
and cons now initially I just I was I
intended to send a reply to Marvell nerd
and just kind of give him an answer
saying yes get it but I figured it
wouldn't hurt to make a video telling
you guys I guess giving you guys an idea
kind of a review of sorts of Marvel
unlimited tell you guys whether or not
it's worth it and so what we're going to
do here is we're going to go through and
just kind of do this quick review and
I'm hoping that by the end of this video
you'll have a pretty good understanding
of how Marvel unlimited works and
whether or not Marvel unlimited will be
an offering for you so Marvel unlimited
is a I guess a subscription-based
service from Marvel which allows you to
peruse their catalogue of coming book
collections for about $10 a month now
you can buy it two ways either you can
go ahead and buy it using $10 a month or
you can buy yours annually which is what
I do I some would just pay for mine a
year in advance and then just go from
there that way I can just budget ahead
of time and don't really have to worry
about things too much but nonetheless a
lot of people found the interface for
Marvel unlimited a little confusing and
in truth Marvel really didn't do the
best job of making the interface clear
to understand a lot of people who show
up to Marvel unlimited simply see this
and they don't really know where to
start they're not really sure where to
go from here of course all these stories
are completely disconnected and none of
them really have anything to do with
each other then so the question is why
are you why are they all here and so
what when you're I guess a person that's
looking to get Marvel unlimited or if
you have Marvel unlimited and you're
trying to figure out where to start the
first place you want to go right here is
browse and browse is pretty much going
to give you the option of what you can
search by we can go by series characters
creators events and crossovers now for
the most part for those of you guys who
are just your casual comic book readers
characters and events and crossovers are
going to do the sessions for you this is
where you're going to look at and what's
really cool here is we can quite
literally go through and just look at
all the events that Marvel has going on
that they've ever had and we can
actually check out some of them on
Marvel unlimited now what I mean by some
of them is that Marvel unlimited is six
months behind meaning that if a comic
book were to come out today let's say
it's an issue number one
some comic we wouldn't actually be able
to read it a Marvel unlimited until six
months from now and even then there's no
guarantee you would be able to check it
out this is the perfect example of the
devil being in the details in the sense
that let's take something like age of
Ultron for example with age of Ultron
you cannot read the main age of Ultron
story on Marvel unlimited you have to
buy the digital copies however you can
read the tie ends for the tie-ins really
just aren't that important in fact
they're really pretty much useless here
there's really no purpose in having them
the only tie end that really matters is
the tie-in of I guess they don't have it
here or they might the tie-in of the
Fantastic Four that's really the only
one that matters because it tells you
what it really led up to Susan storm
becoming part of the I guess what was
left of the Avengers and things going
forward what happened all the other
superheroes who were killed off and so
on and so forth but again one of the big
questions I've always wondered is with I
guess with Avengers 2 age of Ultron
coming out why would this not be
available because if Marvin would
advertise this and say that the age of
Ultron story is available for reading on
model unlimited with a $10 a month
subscription it's a great way to draw
your new readers people will go in
they'll get a subscription the read
Marvel unlimited and even if they only
stay for a month that's still a pretty
good deal for Marvel in terms of I guess
the money they be able to bring in
another issue here is going back to the
to the events and crossover section is
Civil War the Civil War as we know is
probably Marvel's biggest event they've
ever had in the history of their
continuity I really can't think of a
single story that's been done by Marvel
Comics this ever been as good as Mark
Miller Civil War now you can read the
Maine Civil War event you can read all
the way up to issues one through seven
but you can't read the tie-ins on Marvel
unlimited now some people will say the
tie-ins aren't necessary and to a degree
they may not be but I would go as far as
to say the tie-ins give a much richer
and well-rounded story to civil war and
so for me the tie-ins are really a must
for anybody who wants the full Civil War
experience as opposed to just kind of
glossing over and touching on the
important parts but nonetheless at that
point it's really just personal
preference now not everything is like
this let's take for example again back
to events and crossovers if we were to a
scroll
down here which will give you again all
the events and all the crossovers that
marbles ever had in the history of their
continuity let's say for example we jump
to Infinity Gauntlet
alright Infinity Gauntlet will allow you
to read or I guess Robin limited will
allow you to read Infinity Gauntlet
completely it'll allow you to go through
the entire series issues one through six
it allow you to read the whole thing and
you can experience the entire event
attea fairly gone a little bit for
yourself another really cool thing here
is again going back to events like
crossovers is that Secret Wars for
example Secret Wars in its entirety is a
is able to be read on on Marvel
unlimited meaning that if those of you
guys who are curious as to why it is
Marvel is using so are using Secret Wars
as a platform to launch the I guess the
reboot of their multiverse continuity
then you can go through and read Secret
Wars and understand why that's the case
understand the significance of Secret
Wars and the realm of Marvel Comics now
what model lacks in terms of the events
and crossovers and the tie-ins versus
the main stories and so on they make up
for with their characters and in fact I
would go as far as to say they do this
in spectacular fashion and what we have
here are the highlight characters these
are some of the more prominent
characters and teams and Marvel Comics
Spider Man Thor the x-men storm and so
on but if we scroll down here we have
every single character this ever
appeared in Marvel Comics from the
characters who have appeared in single
comics all the way to characters like
Wolverine who have appeared in more
comics than anybody else and so this
would be a great way for people to go
through and read about individual
characters and so let's say for example
that with Captain America three Civil
War coming out soon that Marvel
basically tells us that Frank rumlow is
going to be playing crossbones one of
the more formidable enemies of Captain
America you could go through here you
could go into Marvel unlimited you could
scroll down to crossbones and what you
can do is you can check this box right
here that says Marvel unlimited and it
will give you all the offerings that
Marvel has with regards to crossbones
and the Marvel unlimited unlimited
catalog now again this really is there
really isn't a whole lot here there's
only about 19 offerings but some of
these are a complete issue some of these
are stories and so on and so forth but
it'll give you a well-rounded eye
dia of a favor I'm sorry about
crossbones within the realm of of Marvel
Comics and so again Marvel unlimited is
a great great offering for people who
are looking to get into comics and one
of the none if Achatz about some of the
older stories it's really not so great
for people who want to stay current with
comic books but those people who are
going out and they're wanting to stake
her they're one to get all the newest
stories most likely have a pull list
anyway at the local comic book store but
the fact remains that Marvel unlimited
is a great option for people to get into
comics to read a lot of older comics to
learn about a lot of older things and
the significance of some of these older
stories but that being said I hope this
video was informative I hope you guys
enjoyed it if you did let me know and I
will catch you guys later peace be sure
to follow me on Twitter there you can
keep up with all the updates from comics
explained and talk to me directly